Don't miss this new game that is rocking it.
and is also available for free on Game Pass.
VA of animal fights,
but their crazy physique
make it ideal for playing with friends
whom we will have to betray in order to win.
Each Round will be shared between several animals
and also put costumes on them.
It has several game modes
in which we can compete alone or as a team,
plus 1 lot of levels,
to each his own crazier
and with 1 enormous amount of weapons and objects
that we can pick up and throw freely.
This complete animal is called party animal
and although it is currently only available on Xbox and PC,
its developers plan to launch it as well
in yellow,
Nintendo Switch and mobile devices.